I like it here it makes me a peaceful  you're not from around here are you  every time what was your job I was in  this you know business as you know we  manage the investments of our employees  if a former agent dies after retirement  we're eight million dollars  there's back to the company this is a  bad idea  somebody set me up over here great you  have nothing to do with it you tried to  kill the black heist and kidnaps cute  little neighborhood  we should paint so we don't have to look  over our shoulder for the rest of our  lives  you'll need all of it try not to be  scared make mistakes when you're afraid  thought you stopped smoking figured it  wouldn't kill me  why are you doing this I like  you're not a good man you're doing a  good thing  [Music]  did you happen to see anything peculiar  at the past couple days  No  [Music]